M check M
check
yeah
uh thank you councilors um we'll um
start with the uh next meeting which is
the ground subcommittee meeting and
apologize for being a bit late with the
council meeting itself prior to it was
just a little bit over schedule but uh
welcome to all counselors and members of
the public and also those presenting
today for the grant so uh we'll start
off with any apologies from any
councilors if not can I move in a second
for those
please a
second thank
you any Declarations of conflict of
interest for any of the
grants thank
you
no nothing
further um yes ke on the um War's trust
but um as a council representative I'm
going to probably get them just say a
few words on behalf of them anyway so if
there's any Council that's on any
representation of the grants today I I
more than welcome to make a comment if
you so wish I have no problem with
that so we carry on with the uh
presentations
of scheduled grants today and and
welcome the py Lions trust and preser
Neil M if you like to just come forward
and grab a seat over there and I'll get
start to turn the mic on for
you
thank
you do you want me to say
something
well it uh
gives me privilege U I consider a
privilege to come along and have the
opportunity to um meet the
committee and uh first of all I would
like to express our gratitude on behalf
of my fellow
recyclers for your encouragement and
help both financial and uh in and in
kind the and especially uh speaking
perhaps
um um to the previous staff um Steve
Perry and his team and other names that
come to
um uh to mind are Paul Withers and the
staff When U we first approached and uh
I can well remember coming
probably 15 years
ago um just letting us know letting
Council know that we were in in
existence and would like a little bit of
financial help help and it was get like
getting blood out of a
stone but uh things have changed since
then and we've changed and got a little
older just perhaps too
old um now as far as you have all the
information that I handed to
you
um and to start off well you realize
that we are the only recyclers in
town and we
really
um our mission is to um reduce
the uh the product that otherwise would
go to the
landfill at a great cost to the rate
power and as well in our resistance up
there we consider we're achieving that
uh economically
and uh in uh
fact uh returning or making a profit at
times and I I emphasis size at times two
years ago we were receiving a princely
sum of $200 a ton for
cardboard and now it's
$50 and I can assure you you can't make
any
money at $50 even if you've got
volunteer
labor and the other objective if you
could call it
that the that's um a recycling project
and I might might remind you when uh
you're looking at the um the figures of
our the club that we not only recycle we
do have other activities that realize
um uh
Revenue that uh the other um objective
is to can I call it a wellness program
that 20 people up to 20 usually about 12
or 13 each day each
morning uh come along and enjoy each
other's company and if you want a
conclusion if you want an opinion on any
subject uh we've probably got about 500
years of
experience so that
in a
nutshell that's what we exist to and
what we carry on and I like to think
that we have also created um as well a
center for
recycling but the old skating rink was
the
um available at that time and
uh if um if we uh if we look back to the
building in 2003 when we um bought the
building and uh turned it into
Recycling and with the assistance of you
people go Council and the environment
South and and
NLT set
up uh the press and uh went ahead with
um
um uh
processing the uh car
cardboard um only cardboard for a SL and
then we included film or
plastic and uh and
newspapers and uh as you see if you read
your history lesson that um what has
happened since
then and the only um well the only other
thing that when I was looking through
the record is that the surpluses we have
had just on a few um uh to name you've
got a list of um donations in
20 20
um uh and it's interesting when I was
looking at the agenda for this meeting
that um the
schools didn't make an application but I
I assume that that what they're applying
for was swimming and uh five years ago
when the gore District
Council
um changed their mind about supporting
them or for whatever reason we took up
the slack and U we've been doing that
10,000 a year uh ever
since and and I like to think that
sometimes that um we are able to um
provide facilities with the setup that
we have and with in the relationship
that we have with with you as a council
that we can provide things for the town
which might be on your wish list but uh
that um it's
um and and we have done it in the past
so we we do keep in close contact with
with the
uh and uh so the projects this swimming
we actually 50,000 to the St John's
building when it was
building 10,000 to the association for
various bits and
pieces and the helicopter uh two years
in a row we
provided
20,000 riding for the disabled shelter
for six ponies
5,000 so that's um I think
U about all I would uh like to
well all I can say we're
um we're happy in our work up there and
as you see as far as air has
worked the approximate airs that U
adding up the
airs um
is 150 hours a week and this is a year
round project I had had a a bit of a
difficulty when I was filling in the
application
form um that it was specific
uh re um requiring information on a
particular project well all our projects
and this is only one one aspect of of
the
allines and the thing too is when I'm
here
I most hardly thank all the um uh
individuals the active members and now
we have uh almost 50%
of uh people that are not members of um
the Lions Club and during the years we
have also
had work experience of people from Gore
high
school and uh and one particular lad he
his father was
um um killed in the TV building that uh
in Christ Church and when he came down
he wouldn't even leave home uh to go to
the shop across the road from us
but uh By the time he'd been with us he
would gladly come
down um and recognized us perhaps as a
substitute for his father who had lost
in the in the
earthquake so
um yes I I don't know whether there's
anything
else is there any any anybody got
any
let me just say uh well in and and the
only figure one figure that I would
quote is that
um at the moment we're about 650 tons a
year which would cost just over 12,000
to send a
landfill so if if you guys were paying
50,000 a year you're still making uh I
know you're not paying
50,000
so so and and and we haven't got any
hidden hidden bank accounts uh we might
sell a couple of P packets so that we
can have a bag of biscuits and uh I
suppose I would say that
um uh the uh is um but um so all all the
Surplus goes back and I think it's fair
to say that once we got mobile well we
have bought
trucks but again I reiterate that the
district council has been really good if
a truck broke down well they' help us
out and uh and we we really value the
relationship we have with with you
people thanks for the opportunity to now
look thank you thank you very much um
for your presentation um um I'll just
pass it on to any Council as award the
worship if there's any questions they
put forward to the parking
L Council thank you Mr chair um I don't
have a question I'd just like to make a
comment I think I couldn't really think
of a more worthy cause for Council to be
giving its funding too because you do
such a great job for a district um you
save Council funding you actually
provide social social services for a lot
of people in the town the older
generation who can get together and and
have a chat and chew the fat and um and
I just think it's a it's a really great
Enterprise that you're doing and I wish
you all the best thank you for what you
do thanks for
that uh Council Stringer then councel
McKenzie uh thank you Mr M powerful
coming along um very insightful and you
choose for your um work that you're
doing for the community as a as a group
there um just a couple of questions
around um your statement of receipts and
payments I I see there's a lot of line
items there come through this year that
you're not making income from is that
um is that just a trend that we're
seeing going forward or you expect that
things are going to pick
up uh well the actually pricing of our
product we get a price 3
months originally when we started off we
we had a guaranteed price but um we and
that's well 27 years ago but the uh as
far as the it's very Vol volatile at the
moment uh at the beginning of this year
I think we it was about
$63 and the last from the first to
November it um was
$50 and newspaper we are paying to send
newspaper way $10 a
ton um the um plastic film is actually
two
$235 a ton like where it's good money
but you can imagine it takes a lot of
plastic
to and actually from figures air figures
we we uh produce about 25 ton of plastic
but uh
um yeah yeah
and it seems as though we're dependent
on
China China says no we don't want
it in fact even the I heard a
story about a he got that um um
annoyed with his own country that he
packed his Mill up took it to Malaysia
and uh operated from there but
uh
and yeah yeah there's one thing I I was
thinking about um that I didn't mention
it's not really you
know associated with what we're talking
about is that the time may come when the
piki Lions have to look at uh well we're
get a bit old and U might have
to um well recruit regroup you like I
mean join or have some
more closer relationship in fact um well
I I suppose I can say it I've set it up
there often enough you my bodyguard
aren't
you the that that really
coming along to a grants committee I
I've looked at some of the other you
know that um we're in a different
situation we're actually a trading
concern I know it's a it's an odd
trading concern because we started off
as a bit like
the Hawkers that we had years ago like
just a van and a wheel Bearer or
something and then we gradually got to
the stage where and to be honest I think
some of our members lik
that to where we became a a private
Enterprise
business and uh that has some some
difficulties and and I think because
of uh well can I put it another way that
what we're doing is pay part of your
waste
minimization and I I think that the the
money that you give us
should be coming out of that waste
minimization I don't talk to my sons of
course and that's that's a question that
um us as a council can f forward to to
waste that in the future but um yeah
well that's that that's the future that
is the future so Council McKenzie had a
question for you yeah thanks for coming
in Neil i' I've got a comment and a
question I do enjoy all the waves I get
when I drive past here cuz we live just
around the corner I think you're waving
at me I'm not 100% sure like yeah um but
sometimes you you delve into other
things like a bit of scrap steel and
things like that I see those bed STS
sitting there is there a quid in those
or are they just a hell of a lot of
work uh well the frame the the the
yeah the metal yeah yeah sorry I call
them beds but they still yeah the beds
yeah the beds well how many do you want
I've already brought one off you not too
actually but is there other avenues like
that that you guys can look well the
bedsteads they um uh for for long enough
the freezing like the meat Works they'
bring them up and they wouldn't bother
taking them back and I was never very
sure whether we are own them or they own
them but now now they've said they they
don't want them anymore okay so U we U
actually we talking about just putting
the row of them along the road in sort
of a false fence you know like U uh but
the answer whether there any
value
uh we cut the legs off so that we could
cart
one uh and it uh we got $26 for it
that's the metal they're very very good
but
like well if you want that sort of thing
it's a bit like any clearing s and if
you don't need it you I think they used
to cost about $1,200 to build at the
works yeah they were about $1,200 a f
something like
that um yeah but in I just like to say
again you guys what you do there is a
real asset to this town yeah and we we
we we get overloaded with pallet
sometimes yeah and I must say well the
last time that we really talked to you
guys was
um uh it was after that that we got the
aluminium cans going wasn't it and and
of course we've we've got the milk
bottles um but milk bottles uh I never
realized until we start started
collecting milk bottles that uh you had
cream you know not clear with
like you you got the clear ones and you
got the cream ones and uh the clear ones
are worth money in fact we have um we s
we've sent away
331 but you got to have a half of shed
full of uh milk bottles to get a get a
decent bow and and they they are worth
$530 a
ton uh yeah
but then again you get you get uh no
it's it's going quite well it's
something that might be developed that's
probably something that we may be able
to you know like working together
but yeah so
C oh thank you Mr chair um Mr mcil I'm
just talking about plastic in terms of
plastic do you accept the like this one
two and five plastic that can be
recycled you've spoken about milk
containers but there like marging
bottles and a lot of other Plastics you
so would it be worthwhile you collecting
those in the in the long term or would
you not have enough
[Music]
room yeah yeah well the space it's like
milk bottles I worked out years ago that
we had to have about 50 or six wall p
like fages you know like a a f is that
big that um to to get a 400 kg
B and and and it's
it's is but uh and that's one of the
drawbacks that we have uh we were
helping out our Tetra Tetra Tetra Tetra
yeah yeah yes we we
but but um uh there's a lady in
inago bch Cafe I don't know whether any
of you with coffee there but she's
collecting those and we we agreed to um
bile them up but I mean
uh we we had six fges and
uh uh and they've got to be clean and
they've got to be this and that's milk
bottles of the same the yeah but as far
as the
Plastics I always work on the Assumption
if you if you can get your finger
through it or or the plastic um doesn't
stand up on its own if you get what I
mean and that that's a bit that's a bit
broad it just flops like the crackly
plastic uh we're working on uh we've got
clear um soft drink bottles and that
sort of thing like but in fact we're
working on trying to get
them uh if we've got to get something to
inago well it's got to be worth it 100
or a couple of hundred because the cans
the aluminium cans if we've got a three
300 kg of
cans and we're probably doing about 2
and a half thousand on in
cans they're they're um $150 a kg and
for anybody who's got a can well Sims
Metals if you've got a couple of bags of
cans you might be able to have afternoon
te in
the But but so so that that last time we
went down we had
three so I mean it was the best part of
$1,000 I think I'd like to think um and
reate the cel's um views about the
stiring work that you do up there in
hakoi drive and um we'll make a
recommendation for short but I'd like to
thank very much for your presentation
today coming in oh well thank you thanks
thanks for the
opportunity
so next presentation is from the hawary
P
Museum lcy are you thank
you
sorry
n um welcome Nancy um uh your
presentation today on behalf of the Hui
U
Museum Village P Village um yeah thanks
very much thank you um counselors it is
a pleasure to be welcome here today and
um we do appreciate um the money we go
get every year you've got all the facts
and figures anyway earlier um we are 45
years old and go here and the founding
members we feel um really done a
fabulous job job and getting us going
the hard work's been done it's just the
everyday Basics that we want to look
after
and the changing environment we've been
through Co which has gone and pass but
the schools for us is really important
the schools today um and I have an early
childhood background um went through the
stage of um beginning the new curriculum
T Frei and the schools come for a visit
doesn't matter what age they must take
away learning experiences and that's
what our generation is doing now so when
a school comes to visit they don't just
come to look around they've come for a
reason and they go back with lots of
questions lots of answers tomorrow we
have um a local school doing transport
early transport in New Zealand so I've
developed a plan for transport tomorrow
um and it doesn't matter what building
you talk about at the park the cottage
how many cars did we have um 50 60 years
ago in in our houses one car maybe one
truck um the bank how did the bank
manager travel to bford to go to the
bank building he came by
horseback um the blacksmith yes the
blacksmith fixed all the tools and fixed
their cars fixed their tractors so
everything in our village building
including the Pavilion we can relate to
generally transport tomorrow um we've
had schools studying the differences
between early technology and today and
one group in particular came along with
their Wei videos um and videoed
everything so they videoed the trle
sewing machine and then went went back
to school and videoed the new sewing
machine the telephones the cell phones
the photocopy is the old jet n that You'
done by hand so there was lots of
learning opportunities for that group of
kids as
well um we currently still have um a
problem
with increasing our membership basically
uh we do rely on volunteers and they are
really special um to be a volunteer
because a volunteer can relate to the
early life oh I remember that from
Grandma's days or mom's days um or yes
we can have that you can't get that
anymore we um also have group visits
adult group visits um from car groups to
ladies groups to gardening groups groups
so we um provide that um all just
basically um store a normal entry fee $5
ahead for an adult the school visits are
$2 a student uh when they come but we
don't charge for any parent helps
because the parent helps will go home
and say we must come back because you
don't get a chance to do that when your
kids are going zoom zoom zoom zoom
zoom um so the focus we've been doing
for the last 15 years is yes we've got
the school the school was it but the
maintenance um most of the stuff that
came in to the Pavilion which was built
in
1992 um we didn't have water blasters in
those days so the Lord mowers come in
out the garden shed the bikes come in
out of the garden shed or or Workshop so
what we've been doing over the last um
10 years is water blasting not painting
giv me a good water blast good clean up
bit of oil bit of WD40 bit of oil and
leave them
original uh what we do every year is we
come across um the& show here in Gore so
we decided that we would do something
every year for the A&P show rather than
just taking tractors and cars last year
we got all the bikes off our shelves we
took them down we water blasted we
cleaned the chains and we done them up
as what they may have been used as so we
had children's bikes of 1970s we had the
um chimy sweet bike we had the planket
nurse's bike we had the newspaper the
inside delivery bike um star made us a
bag for the back of that so those bikes
we've got 12 there in total now all
telling a different story of how they
were used in the early
days um so the maintenance yes with this
year just so you know the g& show we're
going to come along with all our vacuum
cleaners and anything that you had to do
with the rug beaters and in the
carpets um so air displays yes we do
have that regular cleaning um we have an
upkeep um just for some signage some
information on them um I started writing
a lot of information on some of the
stuff that's there and some of the
volunteers well that's not quite right I
said well you can be the right thing and
I'll fix it cuz if there's never a label
on it there will never be a labor on it
so yes we might get things one or two
things wrong but um it's amazing when
you actually get the right name and you
Google it and you get all that more
information now so yes ad generation is
well ahead um now of what they had
available to them in
1992 um we have a business plan which we
developed 15 years ago and it's working
really well it still lets us do the
maintenance of our buildings outside and
inside um something every year we have
got the open shed which we got quite a
bit of money there now 34,000 I think in
the grants account to finish off the
open
shed that was the original shed on site
and um it was supposed to be just
temporary we've looked at putting up a
new shed $200,000 worth no not an option
we're going to extend it 3 m out and put
some nice big doors on it and it will
just become a equin display shed um
it'll be horse drawn stuff so that's
that's I think we've been putting our
money into for the last 2 or 3 years um
especially from the ballage from the
hill which we do really appreciate on
that um finally we we have been getting
that $5,000 a year which has been
fantastic and it's it's always well
spent you have the um information in
front of you how we spend it spend it
wisely um most of our upkeep and things
we want to do is taken from all our door
donation so we haven't got too much to
worry about the basic um the power the
rates we share with G distri the G
vintage car club um however yesterday we
got the bill for the
insurance and it's got another $1,500 on
it this year um and the insurance
doesn't it covers the buildings but only
for
demolition we're not going to try and
rebuild the church or the cottage or
anything like that we would have to find
something to replace it with um so
that's we we've looked always round of
the insurance of how we can save more
more there but that's just mainly for
demolition um don't want to go down that
track at all because what we have in
Gore um we are very very proud to
present it to anybody that comes through
and sees us has all our members been in
their Village
buildings we do have a new or renew
pamphlet as well and we upgraded that
just to a double-sided da card um and
got that around all the museums and
local sites as well so in you know we're
very lucky what we've got um in
hindsight volunteers and members of the
past 40 years um they've done a huge job
um towards everything and we're just
kind of like um the main keepers of it
now looking after what we've
got thank you very much ly for that
presentation that's great so is there
any councilors or the worship got any
questions
or can
Mel I got one question you said the bage
comes off the hill behind you so you get
that that's where that money comes from
um yeah so the land belongs to you guys
yeah um and we normally do spray the
edes we haven't got it done this year um
but we um bail and cut it cut it and get
it bailed and sell it and that money is
basically for the last three years gone
into that open shed account for the
grants account to do that open shed and
finish it
off
no no uh you wish not so much a question
just a comment um having been uh through
the facility oh it would have been just
over a year ago now um going through as
part of the the election campaign and
seeing the facility was was absolutely
fantastic so I'm really appreciative of
what you guys do there and how you
managed to make it work with with so
little um income so I really appreciate
the work that you do and and educating
our our um young people as well on the
way that go was so I'm really appreciate
your
work uh Council
McKenzie uh just just a quick qu
question Nancy is the does the church
still get a bit of use do you guys get a
fee for that we had a funeral there last
month okay um but we do still hide out
for weddings funeral family reunions
just people would like to use the church
for that particular it's quite an asset
really isn't it it's beautiful wech I've
been to both of them myself and it's
just a lovely little setting is that
from mandal isn't it used to come from
mandal and we get one or two parties in
just for photographs around the young
grounds as well yeah oh that's cool
thank
you Council
strer thank you through you Mr cheers NY
thank you for tuning up um just taking a
note of one of your responses there and
obviously this is something we're seeing
across a lot of
volunteer um groups as you've obviously
got a declining base he you got any
plans to to get more volunteers or
people interested or um what is your
outcome in like 5 10 years of people
keep this yeah this this is the problem
um we do recruit the odd volunteer even
now then we have um three afternoons
we've got one on Sunday um we finding
word of mouth is the best bring along a
friend and and give them two or three
days come along for Duty two or three
days come to one groups coming to visit
because some people don't like school
visits but they don't they love adult
group visits some people just want to be
a volunteer volunteer duty is huge it's
once a
month um so yeah we're continually
looking at um increasing our volunteers
but there a all organizations are the
same out there but we we live in hope
that the school curriculum will create
that interest to those children to those
parents that will come in and and help
us
out Council d
thanks for coming in Nancy I was just
wondering do you have any idea of the
visitors apart from the schools that go
through Pioneer
Park the what the numbers numbers um
this year we've probably had uh about
600 school
children um we have 78 tomorrow and 80
on
Thursday um we do have a couple of inago
schools um joining us they go to camp
Columba and they have to wait to get
into Camp Columba they come and see us
in the morning go to Camp colum in the
afternoon so we've we've linked into
camp columber this year that um we're
available for those visits we're always
looking out for people out there that we
can support and and help them in any way
um and yes the preschools have have
coming through now as well so that
curriculum is really pushing through all
those educational
facilities apart from the schools do you
get many visitors just calling in from
around visitors um yeah declined a we
but we went down to Thursday Friday
Saturday Sunday over winter no Saturday
and Sunday over winter cuz we just
didn't have the volunteers um we
probably have um hopefully by the end of
December we should have 12200 adult
visitors through it is declining a
little bit each year but on saying that
we used to be $2 or gold Corin donation
um and we're now $5 an adult which still
is very very cheap um and some you get a
bit more um and the um we go out and
about the community the& shows um and
the loaded inum day that sort of thing
as well good PR for
us so no further questions thanks very
much for your presentation Nancy and
thank you um Council we awesome will
inform you about the decision awesome
thank you thank
you
so next presentation is from the haki
mtime Museum charal trust
John
yeah so
welcome you're welcome
y well thank you Mr chairman thank you
for the welcome and uh pleased to be
able to join you this afternoon and
discussion in relation to uh hoary
moonshine I thought perhaps because it's
been going a long time if I look back
now on the 6th of May
1993 we had a meeting which was involved
the gore District Council the time the
mayor
the chief executive officer Owen pickles
was the time they were the chairman and
the secretary and you've just had Nancy
um here and she the Heritage Pioneer
Park was a member of that original
committee as was the matar licensing
trust and uh there was an individual
erel Robinson and myself who were the
community representative you like the
the scheme if you like to have a
moonshine trust and a still a working
still so that's been going now for 30
years and we are at that stage where we
have the working still but in the
meantime we have developed and delivered
to gore an outstanding uh moonshine
Museum which of course is houses the
history particularly of the wonderful uh
period of time if you like from the
early settlers McCrae family in
particular and the prohibition era which
was driven uh driven by the temperance
uh movement at that particular time
which started early in New Zealand in
1873 just as a matter of fact very
strong and Gore and they delivered of
course Prohibition in 1901 1902 for 50
years and the ensuing history that's
gone on with that time and I think it
was most interesting when we had our
function on the 26th of May this year
when we had the honorable K Ellen down
the time you opened your library here in
Gore
she was greatly enamored with the fact
that we were taking the time and the
opportunity to develop and keep our
history and she felt the history is so
important to New Zealand Inc if you like
in particular in this region and in real
terms there's nowhere else in the world
that you can claim hak Ando Moonshine
Whiskey it's quite unique to this
particular area of Gore and that has
been if you like the driving force in
which we've been able to um develop the
programs which you have and the museum
itself is now itself is recognized as a
very Boutique uh but recognized
nationally and internationally for the
quality of work that has housed there in
that particular time so and we have had
this long association with the council
over the time and as as time moves on um
when we changed from with having the CEO
and the mayor involved and we've always
had two councilors appointed by from the
council which have been uh we have been
warmly appreciative of that fact of the
council's involvement support and that
we've had with creating part of your
history here in town as a joint venture
between yourselves and the Moonshine
trust and of course the Heritage Trust
which we will talk about later and so
between the two we've been able to then
bring together these early aspects which
we think are of amazing value to the
town of Gore in particular for the uh
visitor when it was Ian TK was the mayor
and the scheme was first envisaged just
to have a still knocked museum at that
time it was to be at Pioneer Park but
it's changed up into the Arts and
Heritage Center now which is the
rightful place for it because you've got
a great development up there and it's
all part of a much much larger
development and then we're at this stage
now and um perhaps then where we've got
to the St stage um where we have the
still we have the capacity and Bernard I
think is is involved with taking us to
the next stage and perhaps Bernard you'd
like to mention where we see from where
we are now we've delivered we've had
two semiofficial openings but the big
official opening are waiting we're
waiting to get all the signage around
the outside of the building and you know
as you come down and you space above and
all song around through on the um uh
when Hamilton Wing there is to be
signage around there so when we get all
that completed we'll actually have an
official opening which will then
involved a number of um been politicians
have been involved over the years the
provincial growth fund people that were
involved in over the years as well which
provided the development funds and and
of course the Community Trust the
material licensing and trust and many
others that have supported us down over
the years and it's interesting that in
that first development when we're making
it we managed to raise publicly from the
local people $1.3 million to open the
first time so it's been a considerable
sum of money raised and a lot of work
over now 30 years now I'll run out of my
time without a question but uh Vernard I
think you could talk about a little bit
where we want to
go thank you councilors and cheer for
the opportunity to present I I do
remember growing up as a kid that I had
heard of heno moonshine when I was a
young lad so it's just fantastic to be
part of the trust and to uh and to to be
part of continuing I guess the
preserving that history uh within this
region um what we're particularly proud
of within the trust and working very
very closely with the council is the key
messages that we are now open we've gone
through a very very extensive upgrade of
the museum obviously installed a new
still and uh and we now have the doors
open I was pleasing when I was talking
to the council uh Visitor Center staff
last week end that we starting to get
around about 10 to 12 people through on
a daily basis mainly local uh but we're
now starting to capture also the local
uh domestic uh tourists uh who are
coming from Queenstown and making a
decision to come through Gore uh on
their way down to Bluff and that's where
we absolutely see that there's a huge
potential uh through better advertising
uh better uh signage which we're working
on John touched on and to also to
capture the international tourists and
it was really pleasing uh to see that
we've got eight Ford bookings for
international tourists uh coming into
Bluff on a cruise line uh and then
making a decision to get on a bus and
come and visit Gore and visit uh the
gallery as well as the Moonshine Museum
and also to go out to croin uh
Aviation um so we we're hoping that uh
that that uh tourist trade will continue
to increase um um the key part I guess
of operationally what we're focused on
is taking I guess a facility which is
now open and Manufacturing moonshine to
be Manufacturing in the future uh
whiskey which we've started work on and
also to start manufacturing uh Jin and
vodka and we're working working with
local uh stakeholders to actually make
that happen and to increase the revenue
not only from admissions through the
museum but also through the sale of uh
of our products and merchandise uh
through the uh through the store um the
key part of uh what we see also as an
opportunity in the future as I said
earlier working with the other um uh
stakeholders in the gore area
particularly around the tourist uh
industry and particularly the gallery uh
cro and Aviation uh but also local um
shops and retailers and cafes and
restaurants to hopefully what's in the
future um is uh something which will
take probably a couple of years to
eventuate but uh but getting a
significant amount of uh of tourist
traffic uh through through
Gore um that's probably some of the key
messages I guess that we wanted uh to to
leave um but from an operational
perspective uh finally it's just that
this money is really really critical uh
for us particularly in the next couple
of years uh we have gone through a
significant capital investment uh but we
do need to make sure that we've got the
support of of council um but also
there's been significant donations from
many parties uh for this Venture and
it's really important that that
continues for the next couple of years
uh as we start to build up our
advertising you know building the
website and eventually getting other
people trained uh to distill products
and to uh and to show um visitors around
the
museum
John that's about where we are at the
present time depends on whatever
questions you might like to ask us a
question where we thank thank you very
much for this presentation that was
excellent is there any questions
forwarded to Y Council strer thanks John
Bernard for for coming and um talking
with us today um just yeah reflecting
that you're you're building things up to
the point and you now that um that time
and stage where you're actually putting
a a product out there um looking forward
over the next two three years is will we
see the um Grant request amount um
diminish as your Revenue stream comes
online
right thank you your gr request of what
of
24,500 yeah
that well long we're happy I guess if
you like to keep providing it that that
that's fine and and it's part of our
partnership anyway and that that
particular money goes to uh what has
been going to about 15,000 has gone to
the power and the heating insurance as
part of it repairs and maintenance
security fire monitoring and license
registration that's really how that's
covered within in that and within that
of course we have a memorandum of
understanding anyway with the council
and what what their Council role is and
what our role is we're quite clear on
those aspects and so it's how best we
can both go together so you that you the
town can make the most of it because
when I look at this I think this is one
of the great opportunities for Gore if
you travel around the world every
country on many states within the United
States have specific aspects which they
sell they advertise it's their thing if
you go down to um Arizona you can go and
see the okay Carell you know and it's in
a room well no bigger than this that's
for certainly and you'll see them
standing there and whatever they did in
with Doc Holloway now they sell that as
what you can go to Silver City and
you'll see another aspect or you can go
to booill and they'll sell you Boothill
I think Gore's got the greatest
opportunity we've ever had in relation
to being able to sell hakoi moonshine as
something that's quite unique and rare
it's already internationally known it's
certainly clearly nationally known and
then it's up to you that us the town of
how you can best utilize that in
whatever form for getting your tourists
here you must want to get the tourists
here the coffee places and the buses and
the and all the rest of it and Bernard
excuse me and Bernard's referred to the
number of bus tours and and that have
been booked in and something like 30 bus
tours already booked in for this coming
season and how we can B build on that so
I think the the
$245,000 is a is a very good use of
money to try and make sure that we can
keep developing where we want to go so
that you can grow your arts and Center
you're on to miray 2 stage which is not
we're not involved in that at all but
that's going to be Maj another major
aspect for that particular part of your
town and then you you will decide how
how best you're going to use all
that Joe Joe the only thing that i'
probably add to that is that um and just
diving a little bit back into the
history is this Venture was always a
council Venture you know it was uh you
know led by by the mayor uh and the
council and just given the nature of
business it makes sense to have a trust
to uh to to to manage those affairs so
it's um you know I I would like to think
that there will be always be ongoing
support for the council it's a you know
relatively um minor contribution I guess
to our overall funding but it's still
very very important that we have that
connection with the council and and we
do have we make well the trustees make a
considerable they're just volunteers and
that that's another part of the town
which is part of being part of Gore so
we're happy to continue with that basis
and I think it's that's the that's the
key factor though from our point of view
you as trustees on our in our own right
to have the gore council with their
formal they're the formal people that
are appointed thank
you thanks for it guys without um from
my side I haven't seen an Emil you so I
don't know what previously has been set
up to to how it works so that's thanks
for your response
there Council lexon thank you Mr chair
um John and Bernard I I think I agree
with you John that there huge opportuni
here for for Gore as a place to attract
people to come here because um more and
more people are wanting more art and
more history and more something to do
when they get here so I agree it's a
great opportunity and it's and it has
been good for Gore so far and it can
only get
better there's one thing I thought that
was part of the original scheme if you
think the way back 30 years ago Robinson
and I was involved with him before we
became before we became a group in the
Moonshine and that was that we should
retain some of our heritage and part of
that of course of a very strong Scottish
Heritage from his background and he had
the pipes and he can play the pipes got
ear Robinson and we thought that you
know as a as a feature would be still
quite significant even today even a
haggus ceremony today would still be
quite a special feature so ever the gore
if the town was you wanting to have
something that quite special for people
I'm sure we'd be happy to provide that
aspect of it if you wish to have that at
any time as part of an interest for part
of our
history there further questions look
thanks very much for your presentation
about John sorry could I jump in or you
try sorry at my paper U thank you guys
for that presentation really appreciate
it I um you had quite a few questions
actually um just double checking um more
of a procedural thing but uh on your
application it says that the museum
isn't open is it now open it's open
seven days a
week is it should be I don't think the
museum is is open um we had a bit of a
soft launch uh about uh 6 weeks ago mhm
and um and we've just held off uh with a
little bit of advertising just until
we've had factors uh I guess uh tour
around the facility which was done on
the 29th of
October okay so since this application
just says here the museum itself has
technically closed to the public During
the period of the fit out and display
work it's open it's no longer the case
okay thank you no that that that
referred to one stage when we were were
closed totally because of the
Redevelopment yeah no that's that's cool
my understanding was the Museum Part was
still not quite finished
that's no that's that's beautiful we all
um my question second question was
around um your power bow um more out of
curiosity is um how are you where does
the the cost come from of a the total
cost I'm guessing is around
$28,000 a year um and we just heard from
the The Pioneer Group who only spend
about $1,000 a year where does where
does that expenditure and power come
from just of
curiosity
yeah uh look there's a couple of things
on the PA first as part of the mou uh
the council was responsible for the
power so what are we looking for I guess
what are you looking at in the accounts
is uh prior to uh the council being
responsible for the building and the
power which has now occurred um it's
still sitting in our accounts but we are
invoicing that through to uh through to
the council um but in terms of your
question in terms of what utilizes the
power um it's it's a large building um
and also given that it has got artifacts
in it it has to be temperature
controlled humidity controlled
temperature controlled so there's a a
fair bit of um energy done to preserve
those artifacts um but also we run a
steel which um utilizes sustainable
energy which is using electricity to run
the still um so over time probably the
electricity bills will continue to grow
as there is more distilling done in the
in the museum
area thank you for that um that brings
me on to my next question around Revenue
when when is your trust looking to start
making a profit off the the Moonshine
production look it's uh the trust is
just in the process of uh finalizing the
budget for the next 12 and 36 months we
are going to run um a strategy session
which is likely to be now in the new
year which we will be looking at uh
what's our prediction in terms of uh
Revenue around Admissions and and then
what's the revenue generated around the
sale of product and merchandise so so
that that detailed work needs to be done
but at a point in time and the reason uh
you know particularly for my involvement
particular over the next eight months is
to get to the point where we start to
generate revenues that are more
significant than where they are today um
and just pointing out also to the uh to
the counselors um the admissions
although it's important in terms of
generating Revenue longterm probably the
the future Revenue generation from
products is going to be significantly
larger than the the admissions
particularly if we can sell those
products outside the area but you know
then T is are probably at a point of
time to become profitable but it's we
don't know what that is yet thank you
for that um and just a final question
because I know that Nea wants to uh
continue to move this along just for
clarification you're looking for this
grant to be in continuation so that even
when you are profitable you're not
looking to wean yourself off this grant
it is to be continuous of the council
continues to pay for power and
supplementary to that where will the
revenue be going if where if council is
to pay for all the costs and then and
then the trust to make a a
profit I think um again just coming back
to the um the budget and the forecast
and the strategy I think that would
something that would be good to come
back to the council at some stage and to
say you know what would we utilize these
grants for in the future personally I
always see an involvement of the council
um providing some support whether around
festivals around trying to get people to
the town to to you know not only sharing
their music history but you know the
products that we can manufacture uh and
uh and and celebrate this uh region so
you know I think the the nature of the
funds will change over time but I but I
but I think it's probably too early at
the stage to say that it's going to
significantly change in the next couple
of years you know thank you for that
that that actually u clarifies a lot for
me I think that is more probably with
this grant as suited as to help out with
events and things like that rather than
the day-to-day operations and changed it
over time but yeah definitely coming
back to council this having that open
discussion would be fantastic too think
you
you and and and we certainly haven't uh
looked at uh not receiving the Grant in
in in the immediate future anyway so we
we just processing down where we've been
and working through but I think we do
provide a a wonderful Center for
activities and like festivals those sort
of things can be done in yes thank
you thanks very much for your
presentation I really look forward to
working with you guys in the future and
all the best thank you very
much
um and next presentation is from the
Heartland Life Education trust Donna
thank you very
much H look just just uh push the red
button the wi button on the top on the
bottom right the Go
Button I just need this to notes in here
it's not going to be too long brought my
friend with me here he
is and I've got a hot spot going on here
because I think I wouldn't be able
to my B
okay just get this open I hope it's
going to
go first
okay so um I don't know I think you all
have heard of Harold um the giraffe Life
Education trust you'll be a baby Of You'
have been through the classroom
yes yes I I don't want to take up too
much of your time today but but I'll
introduce myself and then want to
quickly do a thank you and then show you
a few things um I began with the Trust
In N uh 2012 12 I took over from or
carried on from my late husband Martin
box who was on the trust some of you
might remember the giant fell um and so
I've been a trustee for 10 years and
this is my 11th year and just we SK I
got a disting service award at the
conference uh last year for long for my
service so that's cool um the founding
the principles we we were founded as a
truste it's actually the Life Education
Trust Heartland of tiger Southland we
don't not allowed to put Heartland first
we have to put Life Education First um
we started in in 1988 I mean yes 1988 so
we've been going 25 years
um and originally um life started here
in New Zealand in n in 1987 and then the
following year um it was decided that
ATO in Southland were too big so they
decided to cut it in in the middle and
we're we're the middle lot so we're part
of South and part of too and so um it's
we cover a large very large area we
nationally the trust um nationally lifee
has 32 Regional trusts and ours is a
very large one um and we
just obviously not doing um an overhead
or anything but life here itself is a
health and well-being program and we
have
um the mobile classroom with
state-ofthe-art
technology um and it the children come
out of their classrooms and go into this
windowless stars and the ceiling and
it's it's a magic spot for them um and
we have just this term um started we've
got two classrooms now so that's why
we've we've absolutely delighted that
your generosity to put us on your 10year
plan through to 2031 one to to keep um
funding us at the 2,500 a year is just
going to be such a God's end because now
we have two Educators to um pay we don't
get any government funding so we we have
to pay for all our equipment all our
everything um and so it's it's about I
think um do it say we um I think two
50,000 a
year is what we are now looking at um
yes funding for 2022 and Beyond we get
uh currently 70 just over 70% in Grants
and then school fees are just 14 and a
half% we've just put the fees up from $4
per student to five this year which is
um very generous but some trusts charge
quite a lot more but but we feel that we
want to get to every child in our area
to get the opportunity to come into the
classroom and if schools think it's
going to cost them too much then they
won't do it so we um apart from about
two schools I think we've got all the
schools in our region seeing us and now
with two classrooms hopefully we can
make them annual visits because a lot of
ours are by anual visits
especially the Queenstown mon area um so
now fingers crossed with a new educator
up there in a new classroom they'll be
able
to come annually of course that'll be
you know a cost for them every year
instead of every two years um donations
about 10% and we have a Harold club uh
category too where um members of the
Harold Club it can be individuals or
businesses whoever wants to get involved
some way with us um donate smaller
amounts of money via monthly and annual
donations and typically for a minimum of
a year but we we like it if we they
would pledge say for three years um we
used to sort of say you know $400 kind
of minimum a year but now it's we just
leave it open because we're looking
at um partnership proposals I'll pass
this around in a moment but um because
Cake store and merchandise and things in
the past kept us going but now we have
to look at
um gaining a lot more income and so
we're offering silver gold and platinum
um Partnerships so silver would be a
$5,000 um help with the
theoo
Southland region then gold would be a
contribution of $10,000 and platinum a
contribution of $15,000 so so we're um
hoping that this has only just been
developed this year through the
partnership program we maybe attracts
you know bigger amounts um and so I
don't know whether what I'm not quite
sure what category you come under but
we'll call it a partnership because
you'll be with us you know Dona with
your generous um donation for till 2031
which has just blown us away it's we
we're so so so great for that
um
we we um as I said we don't get any
government Finance so we obviously have
to find use have money for salaries and
resources and the the trucks now to
classrooms maintenance and upgrades um
and that's all eats into our our money
but we do get sponsorship from Main
Freight the warehouse apparel Master net
safe Hub life
nutrition um and that they are National
sponsors but we get some of that of
course our national office in Wellington
U NSC national service center um they
have to fund themselves too and they
have 10 staff um CEO and various others
who need paying so a lot of those
sponsors um most of that money goes to
the national office but we get some of
it other funders are the pub charity
Lottery grants board the lion Foundation
our Theodor gaming trust and then we
have Partners five plus a day two raw
sisters and a
giraffe they um do recipes for kids and
healthy eating and we anxiety New
Zealand B bernardos uh save the children
fund esma foundation so we we have a lot
of people lot of organizations out there
to keep supporting us which is very
gratifying um
um
um so we also have trucking companies
who
uh donate their time and drivers to get
us from get the classroom from A to B
and uh we have to follow a route we
can't just sort of head up to Alx next
week and then pop over to mosil the
following week we I do the co School
coordinating the Tim table and we have
to try and organize the classroom to get
where it needs to go in good time and
now two
classrooms
um I can't you won't if you've not have
you all
seen disappeared you come back
here where's the classroom on oh gosh I
put my finger on the wrong I've lost a
slide and it's got School District
Council on it anyway what did I put my
fingers on oh I probably ped delete now
it's
gone bother anyway the next one's pep
our educator who does our area with
Harold the puppet in the classroom have
any of you actually been into the
classroom other than me because he
was you've Gan as you here
um um yes and we do have a a costume for
a real person to be in Harold yes we
were at the glossom Festival this year
was was very oh I wonder where that one
went to
um I'll just carry on down here to the
area we cover I'll try not
to I don't know if you've actually seen
the map we we marora is as far away as
we go right over almost on the coast
down through har Wan and then the
Queenstown right up to
glenor um Cromwell Alexander Ry rocks of
man Toto the Middle March and and
Lawrence and then
um Waka Gore tapoi South ofo we even go
into Denon we do um Fairfield that that
bit of area of Denon so we do cover a
large area of course now with the other
classroom it's in the Queenstown Monica
Lakes that's crl in the mon area in
Queenstown so that means Pip's got a bit
more time up her sleeve and we can
allocate an extra day or so at the
moment relle educator um she started
this term and only Hardware flat was
able to have us um have her but she will
be part-time for bit until um she gets a
stablished Ste
um then we've got what else I'll just
have a quick look here what we do why we
do it
um 22% of 23% of young people report
significant symptoms of depression
take my glasses off now almost double
the 133% in 2012 so in 10 years it's
doubled New Zealand has the second
highest use suicide rate in the
developed world and one and five
children feel really sad or stressed
about things most of the time and that
was a survey done in
2018 um and we have one of the highest
obesity rates in the OC oecd so our um
the topics that we covered we've got
mental health and wellbeing and bullying
is another one obesity is another and
substance abuse so even even with our
year sevens and eights that subject is
is brought in carefully but it's
definitely needed um and actually we've
they've just um started
another secondary school theat and
theater and education this is through
the life I don't know if it's got yes I
think St Peters might have had it there
were three actors selected and they
they're trained and they this year are
doing it's called behind the scenes
vaping and social media education where
because well you've brother have heard
all about the awful stuff that goes on
so with the secondary programs are
smashed which was ongoing anyway that's
alcohol how how to deal with the
pressure and what it does to your body
smarts is um finances and how to save
and and that's that's also a theater in
education and behind the scenes of
vaping one so these three actors are are
take take turns around the country they
don't can't go everywhere and um I'm not
sure which of these they're working on
at the moment but they're all available
for schools to choose that's secondary
that's what you might be interested in
that um and I'll just so our program uh
uh individualized lessons to suit the
teachers in the schools so our Educators
get in touch with them say okay what do
you want to work on and it might be um
the strains as identity and resilience
relationships and communities food and
nutrition human biology and substances
and they pick whichever one usually a
school will choose one and the
teachers um will have but we kids will
obviously work on a program to se the we
ones but sometimes and teachers want
something that's not the same as
everybody else so the Educators have to
be very very
flexible
um and I'll just bring up another one
here hard the children yes those the key
topics it's relationships and
communities identity and
resilience
and no
I've I've read the thing so to about
that's fine so so is there any questions
from any have you got any questions and
I'll tell you just one thing councel
Dixon and then councel just one thing
we're in the files for the grand South
Business Awards that are going to be
announced on Saturday in
denen um Community contribution can I
just quickly read you the we thingy
that's came in the paper today Life
Education trust and tar South's health
and wellbeing program is in such high
demand that is expanding programs are
familiar for its mobile classroom mascot
heral the draft mobile classroom and
qualified educated travel to Atlanta to
primary intermediate schools from M I've
told you where they go it engages
children's imaginations teaching them
how to be how brilliant body is about
healthy eating and lives relationships
communities and resilience and their
identity program reaches more than 90%
of tamariki 5 to13 in its area during
2-year period hopefully down annually
tamariki are then equipped to make
informed decisions affecting our own and
wellbeing last year life taught thousand
is individualized lessons at 56 schools
catting for 6,841 children the Lifey
trust is the biggest provider in schools
working alongside teachers to deliver
the health curriculum is a charitable
trust that receives no Government
funding relies on community generosity
all you guys the demand is so great that
it cannot accommodate all schools
requesting a visit in the school year
it's recently bought a second classroom
and employed second educator to allow to
it to see an extra ,000 children a year
and and well that's we don't suddenly
find kids under seats but meaning they
can have two annual visits instead of
bay anual visits the program Services
continue to be needed more than ever in
the challenging and complex
society that we are living in so anyway
Saturday night thank you thank you yes
coun
dexon congratulations for that Margaret
I think it's it's wonderful and I know
that you feel a huge Gap in our schools
because um anxiety seems to be one of
the things now that is is becoming a
huge problem for young very young
children as well older children um are
all the schools in our district involved
with yes all
all I think there might be
oneish or two but yes they they all have
visit sometimes um with at least by uh
but sometimes for some reason they can't
have it the year that they need it then
they sometimes it might be up to five
four or five years before we get back to
our school not because they didn't want
us but because things got on the way
again you see we can't we have to say
we're going to be um doing the schedule
for turn one now and uh we've got a
swimming week and so yeah we try and
juggle it but sometimes they must yeah
yeah thanks for that um why is this not
funded by the Ministry of Education or
Ministry of Health it was interesting
way back Trevor gr our founder um he the
uh Life Education as such was an idea
that came from Australia and originally
he thought yes be to get the government
involved Etc but he and the first
trustees or first people
involved very quickly realized that for
this program to work well government
interference
like elections and stuff would get in
the way um and so it was decided way
back then that we would would raise the
money and remain
independent um and so yeah I'm
sure the government might but it just it
just changed we didn't want it to become
political
yeah any further
questions the not look thanks very much
for your presentation M it was very well
received and um and thank you once again
yeah so we're not Tim taing was going to
change a bit this year but usually we're
on this area in term three so I always
say you know we'll let you know
but tap p on the shoulder and she'll you
can sit in yeah absolutely thank you
very much thank
you I turn me off
now
so next presentation from the
Heritage Center
trust got
the
well than well thank you very much Mr
chairman mayor counselors um this really
is the the essence of what the housing
if you like these provide the safe
housing for our heritage that's the
Heritage um heno Heritage Center Trust
and it supports the wind Hamilton Wing
the district herriage the historical
collection stores and the archives the
group of genealogies it provides the
fire security and climate control
management for the entire premises and
it manages the working capital uh
development projects for the premises at
16 hakoi Drive which we talked about it
previously was the Moonshine which is
the CH which is the other aspect of it
and so this is the building and we
receive uh very thank you very much for
$65,000 goes towards the Heritage Center
trust and which you'll see the breakdown
there in relation to how we funded that
and you'll see the consultancies there
50% of the total cost that was when we
had the um upgrade if you like now to
the building to the standard of um what
it has to be when we built the building
first and we raised 1.3 million that was
in
1998 and the particular the fire
regulations and many other regul ation
have changed quite dramatically and uh
in relation to that and the costs that
were involved in all that particularly
the fire rating for instance 18 mil jib
was no longer acceptable and it had to
go to 20 and more importantly that there
was the rain ran off the roof pretty
well for 20 years but they wanted one
one degree more for up updated roof
which cost $400,000 to do however I
could never see the distance of the
brain itself would make Pitter pattering
on the roof of one one degree but that
was part of it so that's been part of
the overall cost and the structures and
now of course that's more part of the
memorandum of understanding and we have
a excellent building there which meets
all the requirements of today's
world and I think it's um it's probably
important to reflect the amount of work
that's gone into actually getting that
building up to up to the standard um and
something that I think the community
should be very proud of in terms of
being able to look after uh the
artifacts and the tonger of this of this
uh region um it's just important to note
I guess going forward for the for the
trust again the upkeep of that building
and to that standard uh is likely to
continue uh but also as we continue to
distill products uh in that uh in that
area it's likely the requirements to
meet the flamable goods requirements
will continue to evolve over time as
well and that would be um you know
appropriate I guess for the expenses for
the
stress it's it's it's a much simpler
approach actual fact because it is the
building we're just talking about and
what it houses but what it does House of
course is the artifacts in the history
of Gore and particularly the gore
historical society and they've had quite
a major part of it I did reget one stage
they were also part of the Moonshine
trust because they were part of it
originally uh with with the Pointes onto
it uh from their their area U but that's
been moved as time has changed they're
no longer there but they were certainly
involved with them very
closely has anyone got any
questions
no
here uh so just from that explanation so
that the
consultancies won't be a charge this
upcoming years no no no no that that
that that was all part of the
consultancy that was required when we
had the L major development and we had
the um provincial growth fund and we had
signal and the people Personnel required
with that and and we had to then bring
in particularly then the fire um I'm not
quite sure what you that department
anyway but the fire Engineers were a
significant factor and if you if I could
say they were to the 10th degree or nth
degree of what they complied with and
were had to be met to the greatest
stringency that to meet the present
requirements is and so that no that's
just a one off from that point of view
it's um it's just important to know that
there will be ongoing costs around
compliance so although this was
allocated to to what John outlined uh to
maintain your dangerous goods license
and your um and your warrant of fitness
and again given that we're A flammable
good site uh there is some compliance
costs within that and that's again will
be a cost going forward is that
encapsulated in that fees licenses and
subscriptions uh it's not currently
because we weren't operational but um uh
what John outlined was getting
operational uh and to go through that
whole consenting process which uh has
John line had changed and there was a
lot of extra cost um so it changes from
Consultants I guess around building
regulation to around compliance uh
whether it be food regulations dangerous
goods regulations
Etc um if there's no further questions
thanks for uh waiting and we're we're
running a little bit behind time but
thank you very much for presentation
guys and we'll let you know thank you
thank
you we we very much appreciate the
support and and the need and and have
the building as a key factor for the
whole game thank you sry just a question
as you're wandering out sorry cheer to
um go back track um just as there's no
power in this one is the power paid for
by the Moonshine trust is that kind of
all lumped in together as part of the
Miu the power is paid for by the council
it's it's all thank
you so next presentation from
the I don't see any of my counterparts
here and one of them said she might
struggle to get here so I said I'd just
say a few words on okay uhal of that's
that's
okay no that's fine fine thanks
J sorry that um V Stewart's going to hit
a conflict so he can't really join in
the so yeah it does mean that you have a
conflict he's already indicated to us
that he is a conflict so in this that
you're making the
presentation um and the decision making
in the later on yeah I'm out you're out
yeah yeah as such yeah that's fine it's
just giving us a background information
information basically anyway thank you
just I'll just cover off very quickly a
few other points uh this is uh the joint
management committee so there's two two
parts there's the down there and uh
there's the council own areas and
buildings I'll just cover off some some
of this it's quite a mixed bag it's
almost as mixed up as the hookano
Moonshine and all that how all those
different trusts work but down at the
the half the lands owned by the and half
basically is by the council and there's
a
a number of buildings that uh that are
owned by count uh owned by the hock
Pavilion The ramell Pavilion shed the
pony Pavilion the cattle shed and the
grandstands and the council owns the
secretary's office the um caretaker shed
the toilets um there's a part of an old
shed over there in the events office and
there's also some other buildings owned
by a third party the shafts and wheels
um The Joint management committee pay to
the up upkeep of uh a lot of these
buildings even though they they're M
owned and Council owned is a an
understanding that the like the uh the
main uh grandstand there is is is
covered by by this group as well as well
as contributions from
the and the other thing if you look at
their accounts is a bit of money in
reserve but uh with the new irrigation
system down on the equin arena the The
Joint a committee is is uh promised
30,000 to help the council pay pay for
that so there's
a a reasonable amount of money tied up
and with Keith mcrobie we've got a
future maintenance program going that's
when we get into it it's going to eat up
a bit of the the reserves as well so it
looks healthy but they've got a lot of
buildings to maintain and and that so
that's all we already have to say and
there isn't as far as I understand a
current mou so the amount in the old m
is
86,000 not 9
90 uh 2,000 that's would be under the
new agreement with the inflation Factor
built in
so I'll leave
the leave the discussions on that I'll
leave the room and that's
discussed that's fine is there any
questions you
worship um we'll probably get into this
with some of the other ones as well um
but just if I get some clarification
probably more from staff on this one if
we own the
lands how come this is a grant in terms
of doing maintenance and not just
Incorporated in our overall budget of
looking after our own grounds like what
what's the separation reason there this
is his and predates me but my
understanding is because it's a joint
committee because it's joint it's a
joint committee because it's partially
owned by us partially owned by the
society so the for the ease of
management and the ease of a holistic
approach going forward the Joint
Committee was decided with funding
coming from Council to for them to
manage it as a whole rather than um
sticking it out but like I said that
predate predates made that
agreement
so theoretically they pay half we pay
half but we pay our half to them so they
can pay for the whole thing perfect Co
thank
you certainly just if if everything fell
over down there it's like the building
we've got down down the way the the
tennis club coming back to us if we're
we're the last man standing if if the
suddenly the that's got money suddenly
folded up the council would be have the
whole thing back in its lap so it's it's
the same sort of Principle as the same
James Theater trust if we if we walk if
the if the trust couldn't survive we
would end up owning the St wholly owning
the St James Theater and have to do
something or manage it so the simpler
system is to have other people donating
and contributing so as soon as we take
completely over no one will no one will
put a dollar in but so at the moment
we've got volunteers and people would
working there I think that's sorry chair
I think that's a good good point there
St I wonder if we can have a discussion
later on about maybe how we report it it
feels like it's not particularly a grant
it feels when you're looking at it
confusing because it is a a joint
sharing of land and it's same thing if
we all kind of look to we can reduce it
but you're very right we can't because
then we're just affecting ourselves so
maybe there's a different way that yeah
we can modernize it potentially I'm not
too
sure um one of the one of the papers
that was going to come to that's been
put off a couple of times now that's
going to come to an ltp discussion forum
is um Rex has gathered some information
around our current grants and has
categorized them into what is actually
subsidies what's grants what's
UMO and stuff so so that we can as a
council you can decide what stays in the
Grant's budget what actually comes out
into operational budgets just to be as a
matter of course like the memorandum so
understanding and then what needs to be
reviewed so that is a piece of work that
has been done we've just got to try and
get it back on the agenda so that um
elected members can see
it I I think that's probably the way
forward
and once we get a um an understanding
about where we need to be with the
grants emus Etc and it's it's like the
three the list is there I've been
through it
so I think that's probably the in the
new year it's one of the probably one of
the new aspects that we need to get on
to uh St who's claiming the GST on this
there's a obviously a large GST
component to do with this does the
council get that GST refund or is the um
MP claiming
that yeah the thep treats it just like a
normal business and claims the the GS
will pay the GST on the grants that gets
then claim does the normal claim so it
goes around the council will do the same
thing so it balances
out and and that's probably part of the
discussion on the on the U for the next
round
anyway so is there any further questions
just an observation I just like the
caraker and secretaries wages the
grounds maintenance and the and um I
know that we will we will discuss it but
it seems like it could come under parks
and
reserves just Kei Keith mcrobie works
very closely with the grounds person
down there and it was Keith and I that
that employed the lady so it's a it's a
a close relationship and with the
building maintenance uh when we're Keith
and I have a schedule and we go around
and we discuss each each building each
area and we come up with a a plan of how
how the money which buildings are going
to be uh repaired or painted and we look
at where where they sit so it's a it's a
joint cooperation I'm just happen to the
person on the that's appointed to do
that uh Brett used to be on it he used
to do some other work and uh now John
Gardine that on so I I've just been the
the only one left out of the old Council
on there and I've just been carrying on
with Keith when there's an issue Keith
and I get together and have a discussion
down there and decide on an action plan
and report back to the Joint management
committee and then it's decided and have
to put so much money in and we put so
much so so it is we Missy but it gets
the
year okay thank you any other further
questions everyone good okay
thanks so next one on the list is the w
M
um there was no
presentation just financials just the
financials can you speak to that at all
Joe you got any
inside so from past so from past memory
the white ker domain is uh basically the
land out front of the rugby grounds is
that is that
correct and and we paid for the mowing
of it and I think
that's that's about all and it was just
a bit of Maintenance a drainage and
things like that I think just so once
again it could be that we look at that
as part of as part of the scenario I
think they once that didn't submit yes
despite
yeah so I think was about 25 Grand was
itct 18 I think 18 yeah
right
and I think that was probably more what
it was
c yeah just having been on that board
years ago
um so the grant coming in I I know at
one stage they were after a new tractor
and and that and I think they got a hand
me down from the council or something
like that yeah um so I think it probably
is something it does need looked at and
tided up as to to how it can be here or
done and I think probably the last time
it was submitted was councel well ex
councel of hug I think would have been
the probably the submitter at the time
to the board the grants
board so that's probably something that
you just flag
please thanks very much any further
questions on that okay if not thanks
we'll move
on so number eight is the mobility
scheme you've got three there that
there's no present and I've got a
rumbling
tummy and you ask me to stay in any
questions on do you want me to move it
down to the number 10 that would be
greatly appreciated that is not a
problem so we'll go back down to the
South Ms Home Trust um and I've asked
Keith to stay um as he is now the
counselor uh repes representative for us
and I just asked if he's got anything
like to
say oh it went off thank you the wm's
home homes trust if I just um bring it
here um provides for the want of a
better word um subsidies through araru
Synergy to enable um insulation and Home
Heating And depending on whether you're
a home owner or rental property owner or
a home uh owner or occupy on the um uh
what is it Community Services card as as
to the amount of contribution that you
get out of the fo War homes trust um if
you don't have a community services card
or you're not a tenant with a community
services card uh the warm homes trust or
sorry through our rur energy um can
arrange finance options at at attractive
rates but if um you're a landlord with
someone with Community Services card or
you've got one yourself um then um for a
small proportion of the cost of
undertaking insulation and Home Heating
um the house can be upgraded
and the South and warm homes trust pays
15% of the cost um in some cases and um
normally uh up to 80% from EA um but in
areas of the country which includes I
think parts of Bluffin and Vago it can
be um they the home gets it virtually
with no contribution at all um so by the
money that the council gives each year
and I think it's only
15,000 um sfold so
$105,000 worth of benefit acrs from it
to people to get insulation and heating
in their homes and when you look at the
Energy savings of doing that and the
health
savings um it's a damn good investment
that's coming from Council in terms of
one of its well-beings um in terms of um
Community um well-being um I highlight
that um I'm not yet a trustee that
happens in about 2 weeks time at at the
AGM um so if there's any other questions
that come up I'll happy to help if I
can and um want to something yeah so
something has to bear in mind is that um
the council had operated a clean ear
loan scheme for for locals it wasn't
well received and given the changes in
the um contracts commercial contracts
act we would have to now become register
registered Financial providers and get
certified and everything if we want to
continue that scheme so Council made a
decision to not take any more
applications so if we're wanting to help
our community this is one of the few
ways that we can do without um and still
provide that service in the report
you'll see that in 2122 82 homes in Gore
received benefits from the insulation
program and 74 received it from for the
heating he the heating program for 2122
um you compare that to Southland are
paying double what we are towards this
trust and in Southland 72 compared to
our 74 received Heating subsidization
and 110 versus 82 for the insulation
subsidizing program so we are benefit
our community has been benefiting from
this thanks very much La council did you
have a
question thank you Mr China that
answered my question thank thank
you no it's it's proven not only in the
amount of times I see the the Synergy
vehicle coming through to go to do work
but it's uh the statistics also show
what value it is so thank
you any further questions for Keith he's
very hungry
obviously I just don't want him to start
eating me that was because I can't see
him
coming yeah yeah thank you very much for
staying so was there any further
questions and then on
um then on the Total Mobility scheme we
go back to that number eight any
questions on
that I don't have a question I just want
to say it is a good scheme and I I think
we should continue to support it okay
thank you
La do you want to yeah I'll just um this
is another one of those ones that isn't
really a grant we get invoiced by theago
City Council on a regular basis and it's
an agreement we've we've been entered
into so they don't view it as a ground
and so in future I believe it will
probably come out of out of Grants going
forward no it's going to be really good
to uh finally get a grant schemes tided
up into exactly what's granting and
what's use and stuff and then then we
know exactly where to go so just on that
just circling back to the conversation
we were having before around the domain
uh in rx's paper it was put in G dist
Street Council subcommittee so it's
grouped in with rural halls and
scholarships so basically something that
should be more or less internal um as
for um an addition that we should make I
agree with um laay there um it is
current Total Mobility is current the
grant funding um that can probably be
put into that internal stuff as well um
which would um make the table that's
more yeah I can I can share this
document with um the committee as well
to get a time before it comes forward if
people want thank
you uh and the final one is uh item
number nine which is the uh ecl West
glore witha School swimming
lessons and the benefit it comes from
there and I this has been an ongoing um
support
for I know this is my third term Council
was before that so um Mata started
the it started off in Mata when they
shut the pool and the Council of the day
decided to uh support Mata school to go
to swim in the uh District's districts
pool which was in Gore uh and they
started the funding then and they've
continued to do so uh I think it's
28,000 I think it was at the time and I
think it's still that at that cost and
then it was widen to the old schools uh
and you heard
before from the lions py lions about uh
there was a little bit of controversy
over some of the cost uh in reducing it
and the Parky Lions stepped in and uh
helped pay for the extra cost at the
time and have continued to do so as
well um for me I I know there's no
presentation here but for me I think
it's uh one of those well-being
situations that once again that we we we
look at and I think it's value for money
is there any things you want to bring on
bring on
La so any questions cat on string sorry
yeah um so has the grant amount not
increased over the past three terms
or since since I've been on the well
since I've been on the grants committee
and this will be my you know since the
break this will be the third my third
term it hasn't
altered it's been
28832 for the last several
years so just looking at inflation
and pressures and that is that adequate
for for what we need to cover or what
they need to
cover um I think if if they wanted an
increase then they would have been here
to perhaps think about it but
um it's probably a question that we may
be able to ask as part of the thing
we'll know you head
something yeah so this is an internal
transfer to from the grants to a aquatic
to cover off the fees
so where we would need to do the
exercise is to see whether the cost of
providing that service has moved and
whether we uh whether the quad is
actually picking out more than what than
what the actual cost is the other area
that we do provide a grant a physical
Grant is to mat school for the
transportation of them to come through
which is completely reasonable given the
pool's no longer down
there so so is this another one that
needs to be modernized and again is
taking out that chunk of the Aquatic
Center stuff and just the grant is
literally for transport which we pay to
the school i' imagine
yeah it's bringing all these things that
he really and and a big to was
required
y any further
questions right so uh anyone got
anything else they want to bring forward
about any of the uh items on schedule
today on the agenda sorry Mr chtis
correction to what I just said sorry the
they are actually already separated so
the free swim school is your
28832 and then we give $4,000 for matota
school free swimming less and transport
that's right so they are yeah they are
separate at the moment sorry my
cic so anything
else look if not I'd just like to thank
uh counselors and your worship and
staff for today uh for being being here
I it's already quite late
um it's 6:00 at night and I just do uh
declare the meeting closed thank
you